wieder zurück in Moskau was man sehr
schnell erkennen kann am Roten Platz und
wir erwarten jetzt die Rede von Wladimir
Putin und erwarten natürlich auch was er
zur Ukraine sagt
Soldaten und Matrosen
feldhebel und kaum kompaniefeld-
genossen Offiziere generell
ich gratuliere euch zum Tag des großen
Sieges die Verteidigung des Vaterlandes
als deren Schicksal entschieden wurde
waren immer heilig mit solchen Gefühlen
das waren verteuertismus stiegen die die
Partisanen von Minion und pascharski auf
es gingen gekämpft auf dem Feld von
Bardino kämpften gegen den Feind von
Moskau Leningrad Kiew von Minsk
Stalingrad und Kursk
genauso auch jetzt in die an diesen
Tagen sie kämpfen für unsere Menschen im
Donbass für die Sicherheit unseres
Vaterlandes Russlands
der 9 mai 1945 wird für ewig in der
Weltgeschichte eingehen als Triumph
unser
einheitlichen sowjetischen Volkes seine
Geschlossenheit und seine spirituellen
macht und
uneinglaublichen Heldentat an der Front
und im Heimatland im Hinterland der Tag
des Sieges ist nah und teuer für jeden
von uns es gibt keine Familie in
Russland die nicht vom Großen
Vaterländischen Krieg gelitten hätte das
Andenken an diesem Tag wird er mit
bleiben an diesem Tag in
ununterbrochenen Gang des unsterblichen
Regiments sind die
Erinnerungen Menschen tragen die Fotos
ihre Verwandten Soldaten die gefallen
sind die ewig jung wurden und die
Veteranen die uns mittlerweile verlassen
haben wir sind stolz auf die Generation
der Sieger die nicht gebogen waren
unser Pflicht ist gedenken zu bewahren
an die die den Narzissmus zerstört haben
die uns vererbt haben ihm auf der Hut zu
sein und alles zu tun damit die
Schrecken des globalen Krieges sich
nicht wiederholen und deshalb trotz alle
Auseinandersetzungen in internationalen
Beziehungen trat Russland immer für
Schaffung des gleichen und unteilbaren
Sicherheit das System das die ganze
Weltgemeinschaft braucht im Dezember das
letzten Jahres haben wir vorgeschlagen
Vertrag über die Garantie der Sicherheit
abzuschließen Russland trifft Westen auf
zum ehrlichen Dialog zum
Berücksichtigung der Rassen voneinander
alles vergeblich die NATO-Länder wollten
uns kein Gehör schenken und das bedeutet
dass ihnen Wirklichkeit sie ganz andere
Pläne hatten und wir haben das gesehen
offen lief die Vorbereitung zu einer
strafoperation im Donbass auf den
Eindringen in unserer historische
Ländereien einschließlich Grimm in Kiew
wurde erklärt über mögliches Erwerb von
Atomwaffen der Block begann aktive
militärische Eroberung der Territorien
die
anliegend sind es wurde eine
unakzeptable Gefahr für uns geschaffen
inmittelbar an unseren Grenzen er sprach
alles dafür da die Konfrontation gegen
neonazissten bandera anhängen auf die
USA und deren kleineren
companionsgesetzter wird unvermeidlich
sein ich wiederhole wir haben gesehen
wie die militärische Infrastruktur sich
entfalteten wie hunderte ausländische
Berater angefangen haben sich aktiv zu
werden es lief und regelmäßig ihr
Lieferungen von westlichen Waffen die
Gefahr stieg von taxodak und Russland
hat einen präventiven Schlag an die
Aggressoren versetzt das war möglich und
einzig wahre Entscheidung und die Lösung
souveränen selbstständigen Landes war
das gewesen
die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
insbesondere nach dem Zerfall der
Sowjetunion fingen anzusprechen über
ihre eigene Ausschließlichkeit indem er
niedrigten sie nicht nur die eigene die
ganze Welt sondern auch die eigene
Satelliten und die müssen so tun als ob
sie nichts merken und die ganz demütig
das alles schlucken aber wir sind ein
anderes Land russland hat einen anderen
Charakter wir werden niemals verzichten
auf die Liebe zu Heimat auf den Glauben
und traditionelle Werte und auch die
Gebräuche der Vorfahren auf Respekt
gegenüber allen
Völker der Welt und im Westen hat man
wohl beschlossen die Jahrtausend lange
Werte aufzuheben und das wurde die
Grundlage zu zynischen Klassifizierung
des Geschichte des Zweiten Weltkrieges
die russophobie Verherrlichung der
Verräter und die Misshandlung der Opfer
und durchstreichen des Mutters denen die
sie erobert und erlitten haben es ist
uns bekannt dass die amerikanischen
Veteranen die nach Bosco zu Parade
kommen wollten das denn verboten wurde
nach Moskau zu kommen ich möchte dass
Sie wissen wir sind stolz auf eure
Heldentaten auf euren Beitrag zum
gemeinsamen Sieg wir achten alle
Soldaten der alliierten Armeen
Amerikaner Engländer die tapferen
Kämpfer und Partisanen von China alle
die Narzissmus und Militarismus
zerschlagen haben
verehrte genossen heute die Kämpfer von
Don Bass gemeinsam mit den Kämpfern der
Armee Russlands kämpfen in ihrem Land wo
sie wo die die Soldaten von Wladimir
Mona March und Sven
zerschlagen haben wo die Helden des
Großen Vaterländischen Krieges kämpfen
ich wende mich an unsere Streitkräfte
und manche Kämpfer von Don Bass ihr
kämpft für das Vaterland für deren
Zukunft dafür dass keiner die Lehren aus
dem Zweiten Weltkriegs vergisst das in
der Welt kein Platz für für Henker gibt
wir verbeugen heute die Häupter vor dem
Gedenken alle deren Leben das große
vaterländische Krieg genommen hat
fort vor dem Gedenken von Töchtern
Müttern
Großväter Ehemänner
Ehefrauen Brüder Schwestern die
deferanten Freunde wir verbeugen unsere
Köpfe vor den Märtyrern von adesse die
lebendig verbrannt wurden im
Gewerkschaftshaus am 2 mai 2014 vor dem
Gedenken der alten Kinder und Frauen von
Don Bass der
friedlichen Bürgern die gefallen sind
unter den brutalen Beschuss der
Narzissten wir verbeugen unser Gott der
von unseren Kampfgenossen die gefallen
sind ihm gerechten Kampf für Russland es
wird eine Schweigeminute angekündigt
verehrte genossen
der Tod eines jeden unseren Soldaten und
Offizieren ist ein Unglück für uns alle
und ist ein unersetzlicher Verlust für
Verwandte und nahstände der Stadt Region
Unternehmen öffentliche Organisationen
werden alles unternehmen um mit Sorge
diese Familien zu umgehen um die zu
unterstützen insbesondere Hilfe werden
wir an die Kinder der gefallenen und
verwundeten Kampfgenossen leisten der
Erlass des Präsidenten darüber wurde
heute unterschrieben
schnellere Genesung wünsche ich den
verwundeten Soldaten und Offizieren und
ich bedanke mich bei Ärzten beim
Krankenschwestern Fälschern beim
Krankenschwester Personal der
militärischen hospitaler für
aufopferungsbereit Arbeit wir verborgen
uns tief dafür dass ihr um jedes Leben
kämpft häufig unter Beschuss an der
vorderen Front ohne sich selbst zu
schonen
sehr verehrte genossen jetzt hier auf
dem Roten Platz
Schuld als Schulter nebeneinander stehen
Soldaten und Offiziere von vielen
Regionen unseres großen Vaterlandes
einschließlich diejenigen die direkt von
Don Bass zu uns gekommen sind
unmittelbar von der Kampfzone wir
erinnern uns wie die Feinde Russlands
versucht haben gegen uns die Banden des
intern der internationalen Terroristen
zu nutzen die versuchten religiösen
nationalen Feindschaft zu sehen um uns
zu spalten und von ihnen das klappte
nicht heute unsere Kämpfer von
verschiedenen Nationalitäten bestehen
gemeinsam im Kampf die Detten einander
vor Kugeln und vor wie die Brüder und
darin besteht die Kraft Russlands die
große unzerbrecherische gleich unseres
Volkes aus vielen Nationen heute
verteidigte das wofür die Väter und
Großväter gekämpft haben deren
wichtigste lebenshind war immer wohl
gehen
Vaterlandes und für uns auch für deren
Erben die Ergebenheit dem Vaterland ist
der wichtigste Wert wichtigste Stütze
der Unabhängigkeit Russlands
die die der Narzissmus während des
Zweiten Weltkrieges zerstört haben haben
uns das Vorbild der seroismus für allen
Zeiten gezeigt das ist die Generation
der Siege und wir werden immer an denen
Beispiel nehmen Ruhm unseren
Streitkräften für Russland Physik
[Musik]
ja noch mal einen Blick auf den Kreml
jetzt und wir wollen mal sprechen über
das was wir uns gerade haben
von Wladimir Putin als auch Angriff auf
den Westen auf die NATO anhören müssen
also meine Brüder das war jetzt nicht so
dass jetzt etwas ganz konkretes
angekündigt worden ist von Vladimir
Putin das was eigentlich erwartet worden
war in der Tat er hat jetzt keinen Krieg
erklärt er hat das narrativ geändert
letztlich ist die Ukraine ja nur ein
Satellit der USA also eine majonette die
gar nicht eigenständig agiert insofern
ist interessant dass vorherige
Rechtfertigung gar nicht mehr bemüht
wurden er hat weder von Genozid
gesprochen er hat nicht mehr von
Entnazifizierung gesprochen nicht von
einer endmilitarisierung der Ukraine
das heißt auch das Thema sozusagen wir
müssen die ethnischen Russen schützen
spielte keine Rolle sondern eher
historische Territorien die man zurück
gewinnt es wird die
Einheit der Nationen beschworen aber was
auch interess und neu war Putin hat das
erste Mal die Opfer erwähnt und dass man
derer in diesem Krieg gedenken muss und
hat derjenigen auch gedacht der Familien
die Hilfe bekommen das heißt also die
spezialoperation ist nicht mehr eine die
irgendwo fern Weg stattfindet und von
Spezialkräften durchgeführt wird sondern
es ein Krieg der in Russland ankommt und
dem man auch nicht mehr verschweigen
kann den man nicht mehr verschweigen
kann das war ja sehr lange dass unter
die Frage wann wann kommt dieser Krieg
bei den Russen in Russland an das heißt
wann sagt der Nachbar zum anderen da ist
jemand gefallen oder da ist einer schwer
verletzt worden als Soldat der
zurückgekommen ist das lässt sich nicht
mehr verschweigen angesichts der
teilweise ja enorm hohen Verluste
Russlands was aber auch auffällig war
aus meiner Sicht dass er immer wieder
den Donbass erwähnt hat er hat immer
wieder vom Don was gesprochen dort ist
das was wir machen müssen
Geschehen nämlich eine Befreiung und
auch alle Befreiung gegenüber den Nazis
das ist immer wieder in seiner Rede zum
Ausdruck gekommen warum diese
Konzentration auf den Donbass und nicht
auf die Ukraine insgesamt
es deutet sich an dass
der dann Bass das entscheidende
Kriegsziel ist und sie nicht mehr das
Maximalziel verfolgen die Ukraine von
ihrer Führung enthaupten zu können oder
die Souveränität der Ukraine vollkommen
zerstören zu können das heißt das Ziel
ist wenn man dem folgt nicht mehr Kiew
nicht mehr der Westen der Ukraine
sondern ein erweitertes Verständnis vom
Don Bass vielleicht noch zusätzlich zu
dem Gebiet rasson Carson aber dass man
damit ankündigt wir haben begrenzte
Kriegsziele wenn das aber so ist ist das
schon ein ganz vorsichtiger ganz kleiner
Rückschritt zu dem was wir in den
letzten Wochen immer wieder gehört haben
wo es eigentlich um die gesamtukraine
gegen um die Befreiung der Ukraine von
den Nazis konzentrierte sich
möglicherweise jetzt schon auf einen
Bereich wo man sagen kann da kann man im
Zweifel auch
davon ausgehen dass es da möglicherweise
irgendeine Art von Verhandlungen geben
könnte das ist noch zu früh weil die
Grenze sozusagen zwischen dem russisch
kontrollierten Teil des Don Bass und dem
was die Ukraine trotzdem noch halten
kann die ist militärisch bisher nicht
gezogen aber es ist interessant dass
letztlich
also angedeutet wird uns geht es nicht
mehr um die gesamte Ukraine es geht
nicht mehr darum die Souveränität der
Ukraine abzuschaffen und insofern kann
man das so deuten dass hier auch weil
der Westen als entscheidend angesehen
wird der Westen sich doch dafür
einsetzen solle dass selensky
Kompromisse in Bezug auf den Don Bass
macht und dann kann der Krieg ja für
alle Beteiligten beendet sein also
eigentlich nicht dass er mit selenski
noch weiter reden wird sondern die
Adresse ist ja wir haben es ja ohnehin
eigentlich nur wegen dem Westen gemacht
insofern muss der Westen mit uns über
den
und über die neue Demarkationslinie
reden
wie die dann auch gesichert werden soll
ganz herzlichen Dank